The Expendables movies were once
massively popular so why are audiences
treating the fourth movie like it's well
Expendable here is why The Expendables 4
was a box office dud let's address the
biggest elephant in a room full of them
The Expendables 4 performed badly
because of its extremely poor reception
among critics the film scored a bad
rotten Tomato's record hitting an
initial rating of just 15% on the Tomato
Meter after 84 reviews that number
places it among some of the worst rated
films of 20 23 such as F's paradise and
win the Pooh Blood and Honey many
critics have singled out the Expendables
four for having a barebones plot poor
performances from the cast and
lackluster action sequences cluttered
with lowquality CGI in its review lers
sister side/ film gave the movie A score
of three out of 10 writing the
characters are inhuman the premise is
absurd and the plot is idiotic this is a
Saturday morning cartoon with booze F
bombs and a mild libido it's
staggeringly stupid according to
deadline The Expendables 4 had a fairly
small advertising budget of just $20
million and a runup to its debut as such
it's likely that the film completely
flew under the radar for many casual
consumers who otherwise might have been
interested in seeing it deadline further
suggested that the lack of advertising
surrounding the Expendables 4 was
actually a conscious effort on the part
of the film's distributor lines gate as
the company surmised that the movie was
not going to be received well to further
complicate matters the road to the
premiere of the Expendables for took
place amid the 2023 sag after a strike
and the wga strike so a lot of the
film's cast couldn't promote their
projects during the strikes as doing so
would constitute crossing the picket
line vers The Expendables force or its
release in September with little to no
Fanfare if there was ever something that
could be remotely considered as
Zeitgeist surrounding the Expendables it
happened in the early 2010s back when
these movies first release they built on
each previous entry in quick succession
with more action-packed plots and I
bobing cast Editions that's why the
9-year wait for the Expendables 4 has
made it feel like it's late to the party
the landscape of Hollywood looks quite
different compared to the last time the
Expendable reared its head streaming has
changed the way people watch movies and
companies need to work harder than ever
to provide convincing reasons for
audiences to head to the theater rival
franchises like Fast and Furious and
Mission Impossible have grown even
bigger filling the vacuum left by movies
like The Early Expendables films
audience tastes have shifted too with
superhero movie fatigue and sequel
reboot exhaustion growing ever more
pertinent the tolerance for a clunky
action movie Revival is at an all-time
low to say that the Expendables never
had a chance at seeing success after
such a long stint away from theater
screens isn't quite right however if the
franchise really wanted to stand out in
the modern day it needed to grow past
what it once was and deliver something
compelling Instead The Expendables
Forest slid in the opposite direction
and failed to match the spectacle and
fun factor of the earlier
films when don't we have dinner sure
when in a thousand years too soon if
there's one thing big blogbuster action
movies are known for is saring cany
neack for landing cast filled with
recognizable Talent The Expendables for
isn't a complete slouch on this front as
it unites returning franchise actors
like Sylvester Stallone Jason Statham
and Dolph Lundgren with new additions
like 50 Cent and Megan Fox however it's
tough to deny that it cast list pales in
comparison to the star studed lineups of
previous centuries which included
massive names like Harrison Ford Arnold
Schwarzenegger and Chuck Norris rumor
had that you were dead yeah I heard that
too so how's life treating you there's
nothing inherently wrong with having a
movie cast that isn't completely stuffed
with huge A-list celebrities however the
expends has a legacy of doing just that
and the star power behind this fourth
entry in the series feels weak compared
to what has come before with few actors
to draw General audiences in on name
recognition alone the film isn't as
popular as it could have been some wbe
viewers may have also been put off by a
certain shift in Dynamic among returning
St St for The Expendables four whil
Stallone's character Barney Ross has
historically been the face of the
franchise pre-release information on the
movie made it apparent that he was
passing the starring role over to Jason
stam's Lee Christmas for this latest
entry hey why are you here I got this
situation where I need your help I need
B friends that's the change that may
have rubbed at least a few fans the
wrong way there are a lot of problems
with the Expendables for that
contributed to its box office failure
but solely placing the blame on the
movie itself would him fairly ignored
difficult path that The Expendables 3
set up for it nearly a decade ago for
those less familiar with the history of
the franchise The Expendables 4 is not
the first critical stinker in The Saga
at the time of its release in 2014 the
expendable 3 was similarly panned by
critics and failing to live up to the
expectations set by the first two movies
it stands to reason that some fans who
felt burned by The Expendables 3 may
have written off The Expendables 4 just
by virtue of the quality of its
predecessor one also has to account for
the fact that being the fourth movie in
a franchise can be a bit of a tough sale
some potential viewers might be under
the impression that watching previous
entries in the series is required in
order to understand what's happening in
the nearest film then there's a simple
fact that sequels are risky commercial
territory for just about any franchise
some sequels Fair better than the
original in terms of box office
performance but others can't manage the
same level of retention Expendables 3
already had a lower box office gross
Than The Expendables 2 so The
Expendables for is just following that
downward
trend no